[music playing]
NARRATOR: What causes
bicephaly, also
known as the condition when an
animal is born with two heads?
It is fairly uncommon,
and occurs when two
conjoined twins never split.
[music playing]
Although the reasons
aren't clear,
it is most common in
turtles and snakes.
[music playing]
Animals rarely
survive being born
with bicephaly, although
reptiles seem to do better.
[music playing]
Many bicephalic
animals die young,
even if they do survive
birth, by attacking themselves
or struggling over food.
[music playing]
However, these two,
or four, reptiles
seem to be getting along,
and their internal organs
are normal.
So they may hope to have
a long, if usual, life.
[music playing]